hey leute herzlich willkommen zum ersten
video im jahr 2017 ist deshalb habe ich
habe gerade voll bock die anzuziehen
zuerst möchte ich euch allen ein frohes
neues jahr wünschen wir haben ja gerade
den ersten ersten und ich hoffe ihr seid
alle gut ins neue jahr gekommen und hab
schon gefeiert und so weiter und so fort
ich für meinen teil bin gerade vor ein
paar minuten aus dem urlaub gekommen und
dachte mir ich nehme auf jeden fall
nochmal video für euch auf ich habe mir
eine sache überlegt die nächsten tage
werden für mich persönlich extrem
spannend dass ich in drei tagen mit
meiner freundin in den urlaub nach paris
und in genau zwei wochen ziehe ich um
nach köln dann werde ich in die nähe von
luca ziehen und mein leben wird
wahrscheinlich um einiges spannender
sage ich mal zumindest aus youtube sicht
es gibt ja so eine sache die hat
eigentlich jeder youtuber das jetzt groß
youtuber kleinen youtuber was auch immer
und ich hab hier alles eigentlich so
ziemlich habe instagram ich hab twitter
aber ich habe mich jetzt auch
entschieden endlich einen snapshot
account zu erstellen einfach weil die
nächsten tage in mein leben so spannend
werden dass ich die irgendwie
dokumentieren möchte euch daran
teilhaben lassen möchte und insgesamt
irgendwie auch dieses medium snap chat
nutzen möchte einfach weil ich finde
dass man da jetzt so keine lagerei
wirklich ziemlich kreativ irgendwie sie
ausdrücken kann ich finde einfach
snapshot ist die perfekte ergänzung zum
youtube-kanal darüber habt ihr viele
gedanken gemacht und aus diesem grund
habe ich mir snap chat gemacht ihr könnt
mir alle auf snap chat folgen da werde
ich heute abend schon direkt richtig
viel posten meißner chat kanal heißt
krane snap also jakhrani wie von crafter
und snap wie von step chat vielleicht
würdet ihr euch wahrscheinlich warum ich
bisher noch kein snapshot hatte dazu
müsst ihr wissen dass ich privat schon
länger ein snapshot account hatte ich
habe jetzt auf dem account ich dann
heute einstellen werde
ein snap score von 23.000 gehabt also
ich hab das schon ein paar jahre genutzt
und ich kenne mich jetzt also ich bin
jetzt nicht sofort der snap oder sowas
es wäre aber auch ziemlich komisch wenn
man in der heutigen zeiten ich wüsste
wie snap funktioniert so oder so ich
hab's netz statt vor allem privat
genutzt ich habe nie stories gemacht auf
meinem privaten account und das liegt
also einfach daran dass mein leben nicht
so sehenswert war das ich bisher für
nötig halten habe einen öffentlichen
account zu machen jetzt der umzug habe
ich wahrscheinlich jeden tag irgendwie
was zu erzählen vielleicht irgendwas
worüber ich mich aufregen muss oder du
hast keine ahnung und aus diesem grund
habe ich mich entschieden
snapshot zu machen ich meine ihr seid ja
sowieso in den letzten tagen und wochen
so unglaublich aktiv sowieso einfach
noch nie war auf meinem kanal und
deshalb hoffe ich einfach dass auch mega
viele von euch einfach bock haben auf
snapshot zu folgen und irgendwie daran
teilzuhaben wenn ich mir das ganze
aufbau und es irgendwie so ein bisschen
kennenlernen sag ich mal so einen
öffentlichen account zu haben klar also
ich bin viel mit luca und sebastian
unterwegs und die beiden haben ja längst
öffentlich account und deshalb weiß ich
natürlich auch so wie das läuft und so
aber ich selbst bin auf jeden fall
ziemlich gehabt dass endlich auch zu
machen und ich bin auch gespannt wenn
ihr mal irgendwie bock auf so ein
snapshot klientel oder dergleichen habt
dann schreibt dass auf jeden fall hier
sofort mal in die kommentare
schreibt einfach snap chat einfach
einfach nur snap chat dann weiß ich dass
ihr bock darauf habt weil ich weiß gar
nicht ob das schiff wieder voll aus der
mode ist oder so was aber ich finds
eigentlich vor interessant sonst etwas
könnte man jetzt noch machen ich meine
wir reden von snapshot wie wäre es wenn
ich einen haufen filter ausprobieren
ja leute wie wäre es mal mit ein paar
facebooks dieser fehlt das ja mit
abstand einer meiner absoluten favoriten
und zwar weil sich einfach alles so mega
dumm anhört also ich meine es gibt
stimmen verzerrer dass jetzt nichts
neues bei snap chat aber dieser filter
passiert alles finde ich ich werde ich
werde es ein liedchen für euch denn ich
war gerade irgendwelche fax mit dem
handy machen und es ist einfach
abgestürzt weil sich aufnehmen wollte
verdammt okay ich hoffe mal dass da
irgendwie was daraus geworden ist mein
bruder kommt das war okay ist mein
bruder kommt rhein main wurde komplett
mein bruder komm rein mein bruder ich
benutze gerade einfach alle schnäppchen
filter weil ich meine snapshot videos
der moment wenn die gratis-app chat
neuer mein gott wie du aussiehst stirn
eltern gemeinsam weiter große stellen
[Musik]
ich wollte das nicht einfach so nebenbei
einem video sagen welche snapshot neue
habe war ich mal nicht wer das jetzt
zumindest in den nächsten tagen wirklich
täglich nutzen und dann dachte ich mir
erst ein bisschen schade mich unter so
viel mühe ein stecker und so wenn ich
das dann einfach nur nebenbei seine
deshalb fällt mir folgten die leute
kommen wir machen jetzt irgendwie so ein
snap um die leute zu überzeugen dass
soll deshalb dass sie mir folgen wer hat
sich gedacht dass man einfach so ein und
nimmt mütze auf hat im schneesturm
einfach ein menschliches gesicht
reinschalten okay wir sehen jetzt einen
freestyle dass die leute abonnieren
sollte folgt niehoff snapshot bäte
was mache ich in diesem video eigentlich
eigentlich war die esche ist wirklich
nur sagen facebook auch alter hilfe
dieses ich meine ihr müsst ja schon
wissen warum ihr auf sap verfolgen
sollten sich tun also habe ich sagen
sobald dieses video online ist wird
meine story befüllt und ihr könnt mir
liegen gerne folgen ich glaube das habe
ich jetzt zum zehnten mal gesagt aber
ich meine das ist ja auch immerhin der
zweck von diesem video das ich euch
mitteilen dass ich jetzt mit snap kette
konnte aber wie ich schon am anfang
gesagt hab ich das hier gut ins neue
jahr gekommen seid dann wünsche ich euch
noch einen schönen weiteren abend und
wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich im morgigen
video wieder peace out und